welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and as we look ahead to Marvel in
2024 there are still several unanswered
questions from Loki from Quantum media
from guardians volume 3 secret Invasion
the Marvels that leave us pretty
confused as we look ahead to titles like
Deadpool 3 Agatha Fantastic 4 Kang
Dynasty Secret Wars here are 30
questions at the top of our minds as we
head into the year of 2024 some of these
I'm going to start to answer based on
what we know so far some I'm just going
to leave with question one seriously why
the is no one talking about the dead
Celestial in the ocean this is perhaps
our most frequently Asked question and
it's one that Marvel haters love to
bring up after every MCU title at this
point the only rational in Universe
explanation is that the people within
the MCU are talking about it it's just
that the characters we've been following
have bigger fish to fry and behind the
scenes there's a kind of government
coverup operation to keep it out of the
media while world powers try to mine
tm's remains for minerals like
adamantium a plot line that could get
explored in Captain America Brave New
World or Thunderbolts this is the thingy
most of the Marvel fandom seems to be
going with and it sounds pretty good to
me two could all Multiverse Saga titles
be taking place in different universes
we have been hearing this Theory more
and more often as marel phases four and
five keep releasing titles that have so
many plot holes in their chronical
connections to each other from nebula
and Rocket stealing Bucky's arm to No
One referencing teut in these other
titles to all the plot holes with Nick
Fury and Gaia and secret Invasion this
is a pretty fun Theory I'll admit but if
Marvel Studios were to start to say
shuni is set in a different Universe
than shehulk and that those were two
different Abominations I don't know guys
Marvel's brand is really just going to
start to fall apart and will only make
sense to the fraction of us who do this
kind of logical math in our heads on the
internet but for Marvel students to be
successful it needs to appeal to
everyone else who doesn't live on
YouTube like we do people who see movies
the second and third weekends you know
our brothers or roommates or cousins and
for all those folks one shared Universe
with a single continuity still is the
most logical despite the number of plot
holes that are forming but with echko
Marvel is launching this Marvel
Spotlight brand for titles in which you
don't have to think about the broader
canonicity as much I think they will
still be canonically linked but they
will just be less reliant on having to
do all that homework to get what's going
on three who is causing the Multiverse
incursions recent Marvel titles have
suggested Kang's responsible or one of
his variants in the Kang Dynasty or
Sylvie or Loki Peter Parker or Doctor
Strange Ultron Infinity from what if one
of the Marvels one of these characters
are even more responsible for these
universes colliding into each other I
believe it is the Multiverse is Destiny
to collide for timelines to intersect to
incur it's just what was going to
naturally happen on its own and that all
of these characters through their lives
actions just kind of break the walls of
reality in their own ways and they all
think that they were the one to do it
but it's not really any of their faults
they just kind of expedited this nature
and that it's really the Kang Dynasty
that exploits those weakened borders so
it's no one person's fault for these
incursions it's a natural state of the
Multiverse to be a mess it's just that
the Kang Dynasty is egging it on four
what is the difference between timelines
and universes this question comes up a
lot and Marvel seems to use these terms
interchangeably I think according to
Marvel timelines and universes are
essentially the same thing they're both
kind of realities that are parallel to
each other with minor differences but
essentially alternate Earths with
alternate superheroes you have the 616
timeline Universe reality and the 838
Universe timeline reality they're
synonymous but Marvel calls them
timelines when it's coming from Loki in
the TVA because the TVA measures reality
in terms of time a sequence of caal
events but characters in the MCU call
them universes when characters within
those timelines are talking about the
themselves in the space that they occupy
and other universes in the space they
occupy referring to just kind of like
what they seem to see as endless spatial
existences with these numerical
designations of 616 a38 so timeline when
you're an outside Observer from either
of the universes looking at it in terms
of time within the time stream being
loomed into a weave universe is when
you're within it and don't really see it
in terms of a line now neither Universe
nor timeline are to be confused with
Realms Realms SL dimensions are
surrealist buffer zones drones between
universes so like the quantum realm the
Gap Junction the Nord Dimension the
ancestral plane the dark dimension all
of these things don't really look like
Earth they look like weird surrealist
paintings and I think the TVA and the
void and the Citadel are all contained
within a different timeline independent
realm all right five how did the TVA
begin lookie season 2 didn't really
answer it it indicated that everything
he remains said in the season 1 finale
was true that he did create the TVA and
he said that the loom he built to
automatically prune the sacred timeline
and weave it together was destined
overload and automatically reset from
time to time and that it was just part
of its function the series just really
left us guessing how much OB inspired he
who remains and how much Victor timley
inspired OB but if Obi only ever got his
inspiration from Victor timley then
really he was getting his knowledge from
a watered down he remains Kang so I
think this Kang variant created the TVA
and it wasn't until Victor timley was
activated by Ren Slayer and Miss minutes
that OB just spawn into existence in the
basement that's why we didn't see him in
season 1 six will Loki have to sit on
that throne for all eternity I think he
is prepared to but I think Avengers Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars will feature a
rescue mission to rid the Multiverse of
the risk of kangs so that Loki no longer
has to do this job I've covered this in
a couple videos question seven what
happens to Ren Slayer well headwriter
Eric Martin hinted in an interview with
Esquire that there might be a clue with
the pyramid and the Sphinx position
behind Ren Slayer in the void and her
final shot in the Loki season 2 finale I
don't think elith eats her I think he's
an old friend and a pet to her and she
will use elith to escape the void when
oh maybe Secret Wars eight will Marvel
stick with Jonathan major as Kang well I
recording this in late November with
major legal process still developing by
the time you watch this there may be an
update to this but right now I think
yeah I I kind of think that Marvel and
Disney might recast him I just kind of
have a feeling number nine who are the
10 Rings calling out to ever since the
shuni post credit scene the 10 Rings
mysterious connection to the Bengals AKA
Quantum bands and Miss Marvel we had
assumed that they were calling out to
the cre and would set up darbin and the
Marvels but nope now it kind of seems
like the likeliest option is that the 10
rings have some connection to Kang and
forell a coming incursion between these
realities I think I'm going to cover
this in another video 10 where did the
second Bengal go at the end of the
Marvels the three Marvels acquire both
Quantum bands back from darbin but in
the final scene Kamala is wearing one of
them where's the other one Carol Danvers
is wearing it if you look closely as
Carol enters that plane on the Rambo
home she is definitely wearing the
second band on her risk 11 why didn't
Gia get entangled with the other Marvels
in secret Invasion Gia turned into a
super scroll with lots of Avengers DNA
including Carol Danvers and that meant
having her Cosmic Powers so technically
she should have gotten into the same
Cosmic entanglement with the Marvels
look folks the secret Invasion producers
took a lot of swings while not really
understanding these decisions impact on
the broader MCU and honestly that series
just gets more and more nonsensical with
every new MCU title that comes out that
has a foot in that part of the world so
I don't know maybe we'll learn the
Multiverse is a living entity like
eternity and Eternity actively selected
these three women to link up together
and when eternity looked at she was like
H not that one 12 how long has roie been
a scroll will secret Invasion stay Canon
secret invasion's implication is that
roie has been a scr since Civil War and
I think that is completely ridiculous
overall secret Invasion will stay Cannon
but I hoping that in armor Wars or
Secret Wars we might meet like a
multiversal variant of roie maybe a life
model decoy of roie just some roie
completely removed from the scroll raava
and what happened in secret Invasion or
maybe Marvel could just make this
simpler and just clarify Secret Wars was
saying Ro's hospital gown was not the
one he was wearing in Civil War really
that was just from some prostate exam
that he got right after endgame and the
squirrel snatched him there because I
can buy him being a scroll during the
Falcon the Winter Soldier but not during
Infinity war and endgame come on thank
you to better help for sponsoring this
video you can love holiday season and
also admit that it's stressful travel
time with family marking time with New
Years it can be a lot and if you feel
like you could use a little help with it
all try connecting with a licensed
therapist by using better help starting
therapy can be hard the right therapist
for you may not be in your area and some
people struggle with the face-to-face
interaction of therapy with better help
you can have your therapy sessions as a
phone call as a video chat even via
messaging if you prefer that whatever is
the most comfortable version of therapy
for you just click the link in the
description and answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's
right for you if you don't really fit
with that therapist which is a common
thing with therapy you can easily switch
to a therapist for no additional cost
without stressing about insurance who's
in your network or anything like that if
you think that you might benefit from
therapy consider betterhelp click the
link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com neww rockstars clicking
that link helps support this Channel and
also gets you 10% off your first month
of better help so that you can connect
with a therapist and see if it helps you
13 are there really 1 million Scrolls on
Earth where are there humans well we
should clarify that not all scrs have to
actively replace living humans like some
duplicate humans who have died in the
past like Nick Fury's wife some shift
constantly from appearance to appearance
some just kind of live in their green
skin and never go go out in public but a
big chunk of that million are sleeping
in those beds in that basement in London
that Sonia fallsworth showed Gaia which
was another really weird inclusion from
that finale that made no sense I think
the idea was that scrolls are in a
position to try to repopulate the Earth
if they ever want to but the way that
sequence was edited just really left a
lot of questions 14 what is the
political situation on Earth after
secret Invasion yeah we're getting a lot
of secret Invasion questions I'm not
surprised president Briton declared war
on all extraterrestrials on the planet
which makes things complicated not just
for any Scrolls but for ASG Guardians as
well remember in the Marvels Valkyrie
escorted scroll Emperor duie and their
survivors somewhere so I think they
might have established a new new Asgard
somewhere else off of Earth or Valkyrie
has fortified tburg Norway as an
extraterrestrial Sanctuary protected
Zone but overall on Earth
extraterrestrials are being hunted down
15 which X-Men Universe are we seeing in
Deadpool 3 and in the Marvel's
post-credit scene with Beast well I made
a case in a video recently that we are
seeing a new X-Men universe that
incorporates elements of the original
lineup from the fox X-Men films and
elements from the X-Men 97 Animated
Universe what we are seeing is kind of a
newly constructed X-Men dream Universe a
temporary transitional universe that is
designed to self-destruct in the events
of Deadpool 3 and in secret Wars 16
where are the X-Men hey they're coming
in these titles folks but if your
question is why aren't mutants all over
the place in the MCU yet I think they
are and Kamala Khan is just the first
one that we've met I believe Kamala will
be the star of Marvel's third age the
mutant Saga 17 what happened to Kanga
conqueror in quantam Mania well he got
pulled into a probability storm but he's
not dead the TVA case file on this
incident that we saw in the final
minutes of the Loki finale reported that
this Kang variant labeled K 8910 is
whereabouts unknown I think this Kang is
going to learn from his countless
doppelgangers in that probability storm
in master his understanding of all
possible kangs in their life choices and
he's going to level up and return as
Kang Prime the ultimate threat and
Avengers King Dynasty and yes I think
the fifth Avengers film will still be a
Kang story with Michael Waldren writing
both that and Secret Wars and it'll just
be kind of a two-part event 18 where
will we see doctor strange next well
there were reports that dror strange 3
is going to adapt the events of time
runs out which makes sense but I feel
like Marvel Studios needs an Avengers
Temple title sooner than they need a
third Doctor Strange movie so I assume
Doctor Strange will show up in like a
post-edit scene of blade or Fantastic 4
and then play a major role in Avengers
King Dynasty with Michael Waldren
building on the dialogue he wrote with
strange and the 838 Reed Richards in
Multiverse of Madness 19 what happened
to MTO in our universe think about it
technically mto's too many Sorcerers
pledge and the post-credit scene of 2016
Doctor Strange is the mcu's longest
unresolved promised suppot unless some
of you are still holding on to Terrence
Howard saying next time baby but with
MTO we may go a full 10 years before we
see where he went after saying that
because the only MTO we met in
Multiverse of Madness was from 838
Multiverse of madness's original opening
was that main Universe morto still
hunting Sorcerers and tracking down the
Scarlet Witch leading to her beheading
him this is something that we saw in
concept art I actually want to see MTO
in Blade leading to number 20 where
where is Black Knight Dane Whitman so
after hearing Blade's voice and that
post credits him for the eternals I want
to see blade team up with the league of
Supernatural Hunters that become the
midnight Suns which could include blade
MTO Dane Whitman Black Knight moonight
werewolf by Knight and man thing
question 21 is moonight returning well
there have been reports that moonnight
as well as like She-Hulk Miss Marvel and
every goddamn MCU phase 4 title are
getting like second seasons and sequels
you know what I don't think we need all
of them to get sequels and second
Seasons but I am hoping for moonight to
join the big leagues in Avengers King
Dynasty and a midnight Sun's team up 22
where is White Vision well there is a
Vision Quest series that was announced
from W vision and agath the darkhold
Diaries head riter jack schaer since
schaer is less interested in Avengers
World building that she is in heartfelt
character exploration I think it's going
to follow white Vision in a kind of
existential ship of thesis crisis as he
tries to piece together his lost love
Wanda Maximo kind of like Truman bbang
trying to remember that girl who got
away in The Truman Show tearing models
faces out of a magazine and reassembling
her face that way a ship of Theus there
are already so many Truman Show Vibes in
W division and I kind of want Vision
Quest to build on that 23 where is that
little piece of the Symbiote from the no
way home post credit scene we kind of
forget that after Eddie Brock Got Loaded
he returned to his home Venom Universe
after Doctor Strange completed a spell
and a tiny piece of his Venom symbiote
was left behind in the main MCU reality
there is venom in the MCU folks now I
don't think Marvel Studios can use Venom
or any symbiote infected character
unless it's in a movie that they're
co-producing with Sony so I think we can
expect to see a Venom plot in Spider-Man
4 or maybe this is all just setting up
the black suit Spider-Man and Secret
because we know that is coming 24 what
caused Eddie Brock's initial
teleportation into the MCU to begin with
now this is a good question that I
haven't really thought about technically
before the main events of no way home
Eddie Brock on the tail end of the
events of Let There Be Carnage was in a
hotel room and the walls shook the
furniture glitched into a different
universe's hotel room he was now in the
MCU he saw Peter Parker on the TV he
licked the screen like a weirdo but this
moment was when Peter Parker was
initially revealed to be the Spider-Man
this is before he went to doctor strange
to cast the spell that went arai in the
second act of that film and that spell
was what cracked open reality to bring
in do Norman Osborne Electro San man
something else brought in Eddie before
all that happened so yeah an interesting
question I think the answer is not going
to be found in the lore of the MCU I
think it's going to be a Sony answer the
web of life and Destiny it was explored
in Spider-Man across the spiderverse and
another angle of it will be explored
soon in Madam web the web of life and
Destiny is the cosmic force that selects
these spider Associated heroes and
villains and just kind of swaps them
around into different universes
according to whatever its Grand design
is that could also be the reason why
Michael Keaton's vulture randomly
transferred into morbius Universe 25
what's next for the high evolutionary
well James gun clarified that the chief
geneticist of the MCU and Guardians of
the Galaxy volume 3 was not Herbert
Windam High evolutionary from the comics
this was a different High evolutionary
from another planet other than Earth a
deleted scene from guardians volume 3
showed rocket locking the face peeled
High evolutionary in a prison cell in
the nowhere Colony I don't suspect we're
going to see Chui igi's character for a
long time kind of like how Kevin FY kept
abomination in prison for over a decade
so maybe years from now when we're in
the middle of a mutant Saga and Marvel's
ready to explore mutant kind and other
planets the high evolutionary will have
a role to play with that 26 where is AOS
AKA Star Fox well on the red carpet for
the Marvels Kevin figy told Ash cren
that when it comes to Harry Styles and
Starfox that Harry's excited we're
excited and he just kind of left it at
that there are rumors of an eternals 2
but after Disney's rough year in 2023 I
just do not see how Bob Iger will
Greenlight sequels to so many
underperforming titles that Harry Styles
ever Returns the only MCU titles that
makes sense to me are tent poles like
hang Dynasty or secret ORS or maybe this
fifth Thor film that's in the works
supposedly 27 where did arishem take the
eternals I think they're facing judgment
before the Living Tribunal in a
multiversal court that'll look something
like the Kang Dynasty Arena or the
cosmic entities chamber in Thor love and
thunder 28 who bought Avengers Tower
Brandon Davis did no no no no there were
rumors that Mesto might have bought the
tower I guess we'll see when Sasha Baron
Cohen plays Mesto in iron heart I don't
know that show is going to be in Chicago
not New York I think it was either Kang
Industries qng run by Kang variant Mr
Griffin's company or a government
seizure imminent domain by Val the CIA
director because there was a newspaper
headline in the con family home in the
Marvels on the floor talking about
government Towers 29 how does Marvel
bounce back from this slump honestly
this question or some lesser polite form
of it has been what most of you have
been asking us about and while I don't
totally agree that Marvel is in a slump
not with Loki being this good or
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 being
that good Deadpool 3 and Fantastic 4 on
their way and I think this whole Doom
and Gloom sentiment is really being fed
to People by Outlets who don't know how
to get engagement on Marvel news any
other way because they've salted their
own Earths with constant negative
coverage but I'm also not an idiot I
can't deny the reality that the Marvel's
bombed secret invasion was rough Quantum
media underperformed I get it but this
franchise is not dead or dying the way
to fix it is what Marvel is already
doing they don't need our advice really
I should quote MCU book author Joanna
Robinson two words do less Kevin fagy
remains one of the best franchise World
builders in Hollywood history he just
clearly overextended himself with hours
and hours of Disney plus series to try
to connect everything Marvel is clearly
getting back in their Cadence of one
movie per year Deadpool 3 in 2024 that's
it and followed by a 2025 with what's
that four four Marvel movies oh they
yeah I guess we will see if all of those
movies still happen in that year I'm
pretty doubtful now when it comes to
these nerdy in Universe plot hole
questions will Marvel ever answer these
questions have they ever answered one of
these well actually funny you should
mention that because our 30th question
is who was Jimmy Woo's missing witness
and huzzah Marvel finally answered this
in a deleted scene released very
recently in the W Vision steel book it
was Evan Peter's character Ralph boner
let's keep an eye out for our missing
witness we still need him to testify
should be easier to spot now that
everything's back to
normal come
on
so there you go 30 lingering questions
and one of them being answered already
what would have been your lingering
questions as we look ahead to 2024 in
Marvel and yes I am on paternity leave
Jessica Clemens has come back to cover
for me I'll be back in a few weeks but
show Jessica and any other host you see
on this channel in the meantime this
month the same love and same support
you've always shown me thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you soon bye
everybody